[Music]
let's talk about battleship because when
I first heard that this movie was coming
out someone told me that was based on
the board game yeah
and I thought is it going to be you know
a 90 minute or 110 minute movie and guys
moving little yeah
b7 you sunk my battleship yeah the end
credits actually delicately done but the
200,000,000 yeah yeah where they get to
spend the money it must've been great
craft certainly yeah well I'm just
curious so did you obviously the movies
about much more than that and really
doesn't relate so much to the board game
but did you play that board game because
I now I play that game I played it when
I was a kid and it was just simple
behind for 40 years been around forever
and you'd be like II six that's how it
was and then recently I got the game for
my son who's six years old
we went to play it together and they've
added can getting the same game yeah but
it's still the same it's still kind of
the same but it's got like little
computerized noises like oh sorry you
know
it wasn't the same to me but they're
still playing against an enemy you don't
know where they are on the board and
that's you're tiring about my son but
the movie people are very cleverly
used that strategy is still the same
fundamental game right and we're being
invaded by aliens mm-hmm or radar system
is completely kaput and we have to guess
where the enemy is well in the seven
seas and the in the oceans of the world
the movie is really fun the effects are
fantastic we have a clip here and it's
it's an action scene I don't even think
we need much of a setup for this okay
yeah let's take a look he's easy let's
go this is a battleship
give me the Samson alpha Bravo Samson is
alpha Bravo
[Applause]
sir we're unable to contact the same
rough rider for zero for come in with
the force of weapons posture one warning
red weapons tight on everything
[Applause]